tom has such a a high level of passion  such a high level of dedication for  films and movies what's wonderful to see  is that on set you know he is like in  cinematic knowledge having him there  elevates the movie everyone knows that  when you look at a Tom Cruise movie it's  going to be something special it's going  to be at the high end of action the  thing about to obsess with comments that  he's not doing it just for the adrenalin  rush he thinks it makes the movie better  and we did all of them for real  we went up in a zero g plane we were  weightless we tumbled around if you're  watching on IMAX screen you're going to  be so overwhelmed  you  you